ah whoa oh my god hell yeah I'll take
that jump scare any day oh yes I'm
interested rise
and racist now race which leads to
madness and emphasis the boundary
between people and beasts
[Music]
hey welcome everybody see I wasn't done
crowd it just [ __ ] started there we
go all right
[ __ ] hell what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
can i okay all right today we spent a
license we just played a [ __ ] game
how about that this is the game that I'm
really curious about
it's called agony basically you're in
help I'd say that's the premise it's
very cool I'm excited it again give it a
giver to get it we go all right let's go
to hell Bruce if you're ready and if I
can have your promise then let's go to
hell together with me I know you would
do it with me because do you think I'm
special
you think I'm you would do it I would do
it with you it would literally be how
going with you roasted all right let's
go okay
so too bad so far you know I expected
health to be a little worse a little bit
more Justin Bieber tunes and a little
bit more Jacob Sartorius and a little
less you know moist damped atmosphere
that's what I'm getting
oh I have to press a and D alright my
favorite thing actually you know what
this is a joy so far I am really
enjoying him whoa okay so I think we
took the spirit of one of those guys
look at this this is cool am i crying
wow what I am a [ __ ] inhale and [ __ ]
in life splash hey how's everyone doing
here how are you doing there baby you
sad oh don't be sad
dialogues not available in the demo
Jeremy I had it so much to ask
shut the [ __ ] up I don't care you're
you're not a girl can I see her tits
they look like that him cucumber emoji
looking thing Wow amazing I could
describe them all day but we gotta
continue hey how's it going how you
doing let's talk to you Oh for [ __ ]
sake alright what about you
hey more tense okay don't make that
noise because I think I'm gonna get
troubles
alright let's hop back there why do I
keep falling for it oh look at that yeah
but what is that it's so slimy that guy
is ripping a fat joint isn't he Hitler
Hitler in here oh I better sit Oh find a
way to possess a demon what that's
[ __ ] awesome hey are you a demon oh
you needed this oh that's true bad [ __ ]
what do we have here
fabulous baby dude hell is awesome this
is amazing now let's find a baby let me
check your tonsil it's all you dude you
look great okay it's kind of gross it's
kind of gross I'm not gonna lie it's
[ __ ] gross to avoid being detected
hold your breath and you scratch from
who why don't you hold your breath cause
damn you stank all right him yeah look
at that that's cool
who is gonna detect me though I hear
something we're just making that noise
look at the teeth this is such cool
design hey guys how's it going up there
I am holding my breath to avoid being
detected oh it's not a demon that's cool
I can't wait to be oh my god there's
bodies everywhere oh dude whoa [ __ ] yeah
like eyes like high five please okay
then that's cool this game is so cool oh
there's a demon [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay I get it how do we get past it
alright let's oh [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god
it's eating the hand oh okay alright
let's sneak by
whoa oh my god hell yeah I'll take that
jump scare any day oh yes in agony death
is only part of the journey use your
astral body to find lesser creatures oh
I do that every day that's how I found
jacksepticeye oh okay I get it I got to
go back to those lesser ones are those
[ __ ] peasants hey jackie-boy
would you mind open your eyes jackaboy
let's go this is really cool I didn't
expect this game to be this cool shut
the [ __ ] up oh god I'm playing as a girl
now okay I don't think I crouched last
time damn did that demon have big
titties oh [ __ ] oh my god oh my god stop
it hurts my titties when you do that and
I don't even have breasts hell is weird
man I am kind of into it you know I hate
to say it I hate to say it but I'm kind
of into it
hey are you having fun there there's
gonna be so much censoring for this
episode Jesus Christ
wait I could possess the demon no [ __ ]
no [ __ ] way no [ __ ] way
no [ __ ] way that'd be so cool I'd be
[ __ ] us
open your eyes [ __ ] open your eyes it's
time for port about to get ported
boobies
isn't working is it working is that
Satan Satan is that you
oh no he found me [ __ ] game over girge
game I died you can die in hell how
about that alright well that's good I
always wondered if you could do that
well we know at the bottom of the pit
there's a demon there that's [ __ ]
cool okay so we start crawling and then
when we're near we hold our breath this
should get us out of the way I'm
actually scared that thing is [ __ ]
scary okay I think we got it I think
okay
we're did I oh wow this is really fun I
like it's because it's so [ __ ]
different
this is awesome Hey look at that is that
boobies
alright eyeballs damnit this is like a
nice little Rainbow Road in Mario Kart
or some [ __ ] Hey look it's so pretty
hell is pretty good to know there's
another game very similar to this which
is a lot more subtle I don't remember
his name let's show it a little second
[Music]
I am so excited for that game I'm so
excited that there's finally doing like
different things with horror games cuz
we've seen the same [ __ ] so many time
I'm so glad playing this this is better
than I thought
hey how you're doing there you little
ass this [ __ ] hey don't look at me
peasant
don't [ __ ] look at me alright I'm
coming for your demon I'm coming I'm
gonna take your body and kick some ass
and it's gonna be awesome
oh [ __ ] it's flames and [ __ ] I should
have expected flames you know what hurry
hurry hurry
all right Jeb blood what the plug happen
[ __ ] no I lost my astral body alright
fine I'll go back to you open your
[ __ ] ass open your [ __ ] ass not
ass eyes I said eyes okay
I maybe we have to go around what was
that oh [ __ ] it's the demon this way
okay
use demonic catwalks to enter gravity
what the [ __ ] is this game about I press
any key what is happening whoa okay this
is so [ __ ] cool oh look that guy's
bald oh hey thank you for that oh my god
no this is too [ __ ] up I mean it's to
be expected if you play a game like this
[ __ ] I can't watch
hey that's some sexy leg are you doing
there buddy
how you're doing press X to throw torch
while holding it throw it [ __ ]
Oh farther alright where's the torch
there's a torch I'll take that
did they say X I think it said X all
right so let's find a demon and burn
that [ __ ] nice team in good demon all
right they're pointing this way thanks
for help this is so [ __ ] up
everything is so detailed I love it I'm
blown away oh my god oh god that's the
penis right in my face you know see what
happens
can I please have autograph
it's party time and by the time
everybody Dane's in poopie time what the
hell is this hey guys what are you guys
cooking Oh blood pudding I love blood
pudding no I will not give you an
autograph yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
hey look it's baby having a party that's
nice okay Jesus
what just happened
that's a living Mountain isn't it okay
that's cool I must go but I swear
there's been a mistake I've been such a
good boy I swear I'm supposed to go to
heaven
oh my god it's pro tip I again okay I
forgot to ask for our selfie can I
please I've been to all ethics probably
up it's the way you want to go press
while holding tortured chase away locus
oh my god is this just like when I feed
slippy get away locusts
where's slippy when you need them yeah
look at this tongue it's got like warts
on it oh so cool all right Jesus are you
there yes we're getting there
oh that's some kinky [ __ ] I'll look at
that let's zoom in on the bench did I
just say that out loud
sorry strange study this picture I've
collected the picture very nice very
good where the hell am I going
this is so strange what is happening
it's like a weird rollercoaster hey
[Music]
that's where we were before I'm almost
there buddy
[ __ ] lot fun oh my god is scary I don't
like it okay well I think they need to
work on their monster AI a little bit
cuz it's I have no whoa look at the
[ __ ] floor cuz it seems like it just
[ __ ] sees you and you're like okay
well you can't do [ __ ] I'm starting to
not enjoy God doesn't see me he sees me
okay I thought I could hide it's getting
too much I don't know what the [ __ ] man
there's [ __ ] two of them this is too
much come on come on I think I did it I
think I got past them oh my god I can't
believe it I was ready to give up on
this [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm ready to just quit
anytime now know what I feel down I
don't wanna play anymore I'm ahead
I need to see I need to see if I okay
I'm watching a let's play I need to know
if I missed out on something here we go
so URI by the demon
but [ __ ] hand spiders get you what a
bummer
I hate when that happens I couldn't even
[ __ ] finish it
all right school that's really [ __ ]
cool hey it's Santa all right
that was really [ __ ] cool I hope you
enjoyed as much as I did I'm excited
about this game let me know if you are
as well check out another video I'll
link it here but I think you'll enjoy
and thank you guys so much for watching
I'll see you in the next one
stay awesome dress quick or else
something's gonna happen
oh boy you better click it watch another
one yeah check out my other videos
that's how you got to do it now
[ __ ]